do you want to write better youtube
titles jake thomas from crater hooks has
discovered that really 99 of youtube
titles kind of suck and in this video
he's going to be sharing 10 quick tips
to help you write better titles so you
can get more views and grow your channel
faster here we go
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres the host of this
show and on this podcast we are helping
you grow your youtube influence and then
turn that influence into a high impact
and a high income online business and if
you're brand new to the podcast i want
to welcome you we are everywhere that
you can listen to podcasts as well as on
youtube so make sure you subscribe
wherever you like to listen to this type
of content and if you know someone who
wants to grow their youtube channel this
year this might be the episode for them
so share this with a friend well on
today's episode we are going to be
diving into youtube titles but before we
get there i wanted to let you know about
a brand new class that we have available
for you if youtube is your
journey meaning you want to grow on
youtube then make sure you check out our
free one hour youtube class at
thinkmasterclass.com sean cannell the
ceo of think media is diving into some
of the analytics and the things you need
to know about that are changing on
youtube this year as well as why youtube
is the best place for you to be right
now all of that is at
thinkmasterclass.com
well like i said today we are jumping
into youtube which i just love and we're
going deep into youtube titles we have
jake thomas on the show today and he
actually did an experiment where he
studied over a thousand youtube titles
to see what people actually clicked on
this episode was so inspiring to me
because it just reinforced how important
titles are did you know that like 99 of
titles that people put on youtube they
kind of suck and there's actually a
formula and a system for what makes a
great title clickable which means that
people are watching your videos if you
make the best video but it sits behind a
bad title and a bad thumbnail no one's
gonna click on it so today we want to
help lift the veil of that and help you
with your youtube title so let's jump
into today's featured conversation
[Music]
up think media podcast crew sean kennel
here i'm at social media marketing world
and i ran into jake thomas who
stood out because he's wearing youtube
shorts and so as you can see here what a
conversation starter with the youtube
logos on the short shorts um but uh it
was cool to run into jake because
recently nolan mull on the think media
team actually made a video based off of
some of his content that he teaches on
twitter
about really powering up our videos but
i want to hone in on titles in this one
and uh jake the first one is challenging
assumptions what does that mean and how
could we do a title that does that yeah
so challenging assumptions uh
you want to go the opposite of what
people think so that's going to make
people stop in their tracks and it's
also going to make them have to click to
figure out what they're talking about so
this example is stop chasing money chase
wealth so all right you know i'm trying
to chase money i'm trying to work hard
but if someone tells me stop doing that
that doesn't make sense with what i
already know it's kind of
counterintuitive counter narrative so it
stops in your tracks and it makes you
click to figure out and these become
templates that you can use as well think
media podcast stop chasing money like
stop chasing x stop doing x which should
be it could be polarizing in your
industry it's challenging like you said
assumptions great number two ride the
wave the example is 20 halloween candies
you should never eat what does ride the
wave mean yeah so ride the wave is just
like talking about what's going on now
uh trend jacking is another one
newsjacking
just talking about timeliness so in this
example uh this was published right
before halloween so you're talking about
halloween candies you should never eat
everybody's thinking about halloween
candies so just talk about that right
now and that's how you go viral this
video got 162 000 views i think that the
most of the videos on that channel got
like 5 000 views
so this did like 20 times better so yeah
right in the wave of what is everybody
talking about and thinking about right
now that's great and i think that uh we
have an episode that you should
definitely check out of course we'll
have jake and other show notes on the
podcast um on tent poles right and tent
poles will be google trends the spike
around in this case halloween or it
could be christmas or it could be back
to school or it could be things like
that and so super super powerful number
three is move away from pain i love this
example this biblical principle helped
me escape the rat race escape and
arrivals in there what does uh move away
from pain mean yeah so i mean you know
you could say like you know how to do
something how to live your dream life
but if moving away from pain is a little
bit better like rat race like that kind
of that kind of uh makes me feel a lot
of emotion there i've got a lot of like
kind of anger and like bitterness to the
rat race so if you say how to escape the
rat race then that's gonna just help you
like you know that that makes me it gets
me fired up
yeah and the creator who understands the
viewer best win so it's not just where
where does your audience uh want to go
what are their ambitions but also what
do they want to escape from hence move
away from pain and this biblical
principle helped me escape the rat race
and if you're watching this on the video
podcast i or if you're on audio i
definitely check out the video version
because we'll have kind of some
screenshots of these tips that you can
benefit from as well number four is open
a loop explain this one yeah so opening
a loop is just starting a story but not
finishing it it's like creating a
curiosity gap that's kind of another way
to word this
and when you when you start a story
everybody's kind of they have like an
itch to close that loop they have an
itch to close that curiosity gap so they
have to click to do that um so this
example why this was one of the most
terrifying scenes in film history um all
right what is it what is that film uh so
i gotta click to see um you know you
might say like you know the truth about
social media marketing world that opens
a loop that starts a story you're like
oh my gosh like i gotta figure that out
what's like what's going on there i love
that and i heard actually jay shetty
speak at traffic and conversion a few
years back about his favorite title
formula and video format for his channel
which was if your ex watched this like
if you're
lonely
watch this if your boyfriend broke up
with you watch this if you and so
there's something about uh this example
why this was one of the most terrifying
scenes
what though and so it's a great title
formula of actually not answering what
the video is about in the title but
opening a loop so i have to click so i
have to see what is happening on the
other side number five personal
accomplishment
yeah so that's just like a kind of like
a flex um you know like people are
living vicariously through you um so
this one was how i changed my body a lot
in six months um that kind of lets me
know all right this person did what i
want to do so now i'm gonna click and
try to er and try to figure out what
they did um you know it's all about just
like showing you're kind of uh showing
that you have authority like you know i
did this and it just kind of uh
you assume that they're going to tell me
what to do so i want to kind of live i
want to do what they did um so i've got
to click there yeah and one of the
things that this one really ties into is
the thumbnail and one of our favorite
thumbnail formats is like at least two
panels which is like the before and
after so personal accomplishment
what where where are people which is
maybe where a lot of the viewers are and
where they want to go omar has a great
one that did very well which was like
how to fix bad lighting and so the first
image he actually has kind of a frown on
his face the camera's all orange or the
lighting's all orange and it's a
horrible shot and the second one white
balance is perfect lighting's perfect
and he has a smile so he also it's that
transformation i'm unhappy that my
lighting sucks and now i'm happy that my
lighting is great and i think that video
is either about white balance or how to
fix your camera settings and in this
case um you can actually see four panels
so
transformation which a lot of a lot of
us on our youtube channels are helping
ourself two years ago yeah who am i for
myself two years ago or where i was two
years ago and so what is some
transformation you you're probably still
in the process but what is some
transformation you've experienced which
finally also kind of encourages to take
journeys uh take pictures along the way
yeah yeah you know i wish i had more
photos for my social media of the early
days of working in a
cramped office i do have this one it's
like all messy around me
and and now we have a lot of photos but
i want to encourage you you might be
early on in your youtube journey really
cherish this and document this because
what people can relate to is the
struggle they can relate to you might
say well i'm not accomplished yet well
you're in the process of building that
but you definitely want that before
photo so you can ultimately have that
after photo and so that's a really
really powerful tip number six
refute an objection yeah so uh you know
if i want to do something uh if i want
to hit you know a thousand subscribers
on youtube there's probably something
that's holding me back right like you
know maybe it's i don't want to be on
camera you know if you say how to hit a
thousand subscribers on youtube
without having your face on camera like
then i have no excuse to not watch that
so just think about you know i think you
mentioned earlier like knowing whoever
knows your audience best wins you know
what are their deepest like objections
to that are stopping them from achieving
their goals and then uh just kind of hit
that in the title take away their excuse
to uh you know to not watch and also
just empower them
yeah and this is another great example
the example is how to grow your booty
faster without how to achieve x without
pain in this case without strength
training and it also is a two panel
example where you are and the ultimate
result that you want to get what's to me
in the photo looks more like a posture
adjustment and probably some photoshop
which a lot of thumbnails i mean
sometimes you maybe want to exaggerate
an extreme point because you're after
the click but uh that's a really
powerful one number seven is authority
and the example is how u.s military
linguists learn languages fast explain
authority yeah so authority there are
two parts of authority there's one um
this one how u.s military linguists
learn languages fast this is like a
position so
you know military linguists they're
learning something good you might say
doctors you know uh how doctors lose
weight
how doctors beat cancer
that position holds a lot of authority
there's a lot of proof there
all right you know if doctors or if
military linguists is doing this are
doing this you know then i can have
faith like all right this probably works
um
the other way is like a specific person
to use authority um so you might say uh
you know how elon musk started his first
company right
so or you know how sean cannell got his
first 1000 youtube subscribers like you
know that would be huge because all
right you're at 2 million now sure uh
you have authority uh that works for you
there's also um you know if we're going
to go like drama
i read in a it was a book i can't
remember i think it was
joe sugarman's advertising week um but
it was we want to be like uh celebrities
we want to think we're better than them
or you believe them so if you're like if
you're talking about drama um you know
oh i'm better than the kim kardashians
or something right like we want to feel
like we're better than them so that's a
couple ways uh using you know a specific
person or a position yeah and if you you
don't have to actually
be a doctor you might be just reporting
on a report a study
and thus it gives you a really powerful
headline and then you sort an authority
reference yeah to really back that up so
um think about of course how you can
incorporate authority into your content
think media podcast in your next video
number eight is expose the truth and the
example here is from our friend sonny's
video that is titled the ugly truth of
entrepreneurship
you don't want to hear or don't want to
see yeah so yeah so exposing the truth
there's a lot of controversy in there
you know i feel like i'm getting in on a
secret yeah and it's like oh like oh i
gotta click this like i gotta figure it
out you know like when we're kids like
you know if someone's like oh i got a
secret you're in kindergarten like yeah
everybody's gonna listen to it or like
even if you're hanging out with people
and then like some like two people start
whispering everybody like automatically
like looks to those people so this is
like a way of like whispering on twitter
or on youtube is exposing the truth
about something and it's really good the
ugly truth about your niche what is the
ugly truth about the photography
business what is the ugly truth
about
filing your taxes the uh you know or
whatever uh number nine hit the
extremes this is a big one on youtube
explain it yeah yeah so extremes um you
know you're fighting for attention uh
with so many other videos and just kind
of average videos or average topics
aren't going to work out so you want to
do something extreme um this is inside
the smallest department in new york city
so you have the smallest you can do
inside the most expensive apartment in
new york city i think it was tasty
i made a 30 pound kitkat so you know
that's extreme you know that's 30 times
more like 60 times more than a regular
kitkat so just being extreme and an easy
way to do that is to label something as
the ist smallest weirdest biggest you
could also do most expensive
just kind of average content or average
topics aren't going to work so you
really need to take it to the extreme
you know pair that with a powerful
thumbnail and you actually see kind of
the template of some of the most viewed
youtube videos kind of most viral
entertainment content clickable content
all right number 10
make it
weird and explain this one yeah so um
people like curiosity is one of the most
powerful emotions on youtube uh and
making it weird is one of like the best
ways to uh invoke evoke curiosity um
just there's something about weird and
strange things um
i don't know like this is how zach
granky uh became the weirdest player in
sports um like we just talked about
extreme like weirdest um you could also
do like you know strange things that
something does that are normal um just
just the word weird works really well
sure like i think about this you know we
live in las vegas and a friend of mine
jesse uh is in the concrete business and
he comes to the concrete conference
every year first of all i didn't know
there was a concrete cons yes
yes second of all
i didn't know that like what are you
talking about like is there that many
innovations but all that to say
if someone's actually in the niche you
are always fascinated about the weirdest
whatever in your niche of course you are
because your niche becomes so common in
average and boring so if it's even if it
would be like the weirdest innovation in
concrete i gotta know what that is
there's so much curiosity there there's
so much and and just weirdest and of
course that might take some research
some creativity or what would you say to
this we're not ultimately trying to
click bait no definitely not because
click bait would insinuate deception but
if it's it's or missed being misleading
but the ultimate goal would be to have
positive click bait which would be to
get people to click but actually really
deliver on the promise and the title
exactly yeah that's the difference is if
you deliver or you don't um and that's
kind of like why you need to come up
with the title and topic first
so that you can actually deliver if you
think about what's going to make people
click like all right you know the
weirdest you know the weirdest player in
sports or you know the weirdest um
instagram filter or whatever you need to
think about that first so that you can
deliver on that and that way like it's
going to make people click you know it
you might think that it's clickbait but
like you're actually delivering on
something that's really cool yeah i love
that well jake this has been amazingly
powerful episode how can people connect
with you and creator hooks and of course
we'll link everything up in the show
notes yeah go uh go sign up for the
newsletter at creatorhooks.com uh when
you sign up you'll get a free ebook the
10 viral video elements
and that's the best way to keep up keep
up with me also on twitter at j thomas
underscore underscore and i also highly
recommend if you check out nolan's video
uh he really kind of took some of jate's
tweet uh tweets jake's tweets and uh
turned them into a really video kind of
educating on that stuff it's been cool
to see how well that video is doing so
thanks so much for sharing this valuable
content and really helping creators yeah
thank you sean
well i hope you enjoyed that episode and
sparked some interest for what your next
youtube title can be i'd love to know in
the comment section on youtube what's
your next video going to be about if
you're listening over on audio we
actually have a youtube channel that we
put this podcast on video so that you
can watch it instead of just listening
so if you want to go over to youtube and
let me know what your next youtube video
is about i would love to see you over
there and every single week we love to
share one of our listeners who have
rated and reviewed the podcast thank you
so much for taking the time out of your
day to let others know what you love
about this show now here's why it's
important when people look at different
podcasts that they want to listen to
they normally read the reviews to know
is this even worth my time and i'm so
grateful for everyone who has raided and
reviewed this show specifically and left
such amazing reviews this review is from
imagination 13 and they said think media
is the best i'm grateful to have found
sean cannell when i did and think media
i joined the vra family a few weeks ago
and have made huge progress that i
wouldn't have made otherwise on my own
thank you think media for doing what you
do well imagination 13 thank you so much
for being a part of our family here on
the podcast and being a part of the
video ranking academy family that is our
premium online course and group coaching
community that you can join at any time
i'll leave the link down in the
description below but if you've not
already checked out that free class
that's your next step if you're ready to
go deeper on youtube if you're ready to
commit to your journey and know that
youtube is right for you you want to
take that free class with sean cannell
thanks so much for watching today's
episode make sure you subscribe and like
this video if you're on youtube thank
you to our podcast listeners on all of
the audio platforms and we'll catch you
in the next episode bye
[Music]
you